okay so
welcome back
hi everyone
hello hello
so welcome back after the quick break
welcome to the next talk
uh we are delighted to have lori
weingarten give the next talk she's a
professor of organizational behavior and
theory at the tepa school of business at
cmu
laurie has served as cmu's interim
provost and chief academic officer and
also a senior associate dean in
education she served as director of the
accelerate leadership center within the
tapas school
and her research examines collaboration
conflict and negotiation with a focus on
how differences across people help and
hinder effective problem solving and
innovation
she's a recipient of numerous awards and
is an elected fellow of the academy of
management
she has recently co-authored a book
called the no club
it's a guide for bringing gender equity
to the workplace and we thought this was
a perfect topic for all of us at the
workshop so
if you haven't learned already this is
going to be really a valuable skill to i
guess to learn how to say no
laurie will talk a lot more about it
copies of the book are having placed
outside so those of you are interested
in getting a copy of this book you
should
just look outside on the table
and i will hand over to lori right now i
think lori has encouraged
asking of lots of questions during the
talk so if anybody has a question to ask
just
come get this microphone and i think
lori will be able to hear it
so lori over to you great thanks so much
it's wonderful to be there uh or be
there virtually oh no i can see a little
bit more of the room
so
what i want to talk to you about is
something that i both learn from
experience as an academic as well as
researched it's about
how we manage our workloads um i know
all of you are
you know at different stages of early
career and i think these are really
important skills i wish someone would
have told me when i started out
so let me tell you a little bit of
background about how we came to
writing this book and sharing what we
learned okay so i'm a card caring member
of the i just can't say no club
12 years ago
linda who you see on the slide here she
sent the rest of us an email telling us
that she felt like her workload her work
life was out of control um she really
didn't have enough time to get things
done and was being asked to do things
that she wanted to say no to but she
struggled doing so
you know all of us were a little bit
more senior in our careers we were
successful we were overworked and she
figured we probably had the same problem
and because she knew he would say yes
she called us the i just can't say no
club and she sent us a doodle poll just
saying okay tell me your availability
and we'll get together
so over the next 10 years it's actually
been 12 now um we got really we we met
regularly
we shared strategies and we got better
at saying no
but we quickly realized that uh it
wouldn't fix the problem so we were
still inundated with requests to do
extra work that wasn't core to our jobs
and while we learned how to manage it
every time we said no another woman just
ended up doing the work that we avoided
uh
and to make it even worse this didn't
seem to be happening to our male
colleagues at least not to the same
degree
while we were running around from
meeting to meeting our male colleagues
had all these large uninterrupted blocks
of time to focus on their research and
their teaching so we really wondered you
know what was going on here like was it
our fault
um that we just couldn't say no or was
there some sort of hidden dynamic at
work that was weighing us down
so being researchers and academics
we decided to
apply our skills and do some research to
figure out why women were doing more of
this work that doesn't advance their
careers
uh so through their ex through our
experiences the experiences of others
and other our research and other
people's research we really did figure
out what was going on and we've
identified ways that women and their
organizations can fix the problem so
that's what i'm going to share with you
today
all right so first we need to kind of
name the phenomenon
and so we put a label on it called
non-promotable tasks all right so a
non-promotable task is something that
you do
that
matters to the organization but doesn't
advance your career
okay so it's all that those things you
do outside of your normal job
responsibilities
so let me just give you some examples of
what these look like
and um
and then we can and i'll talk about the
characteristics of them
so just before i go on just think in
your own head about
things you do on the day-to-day that are
important but don't help your career
and if i could i don't know if i could
hear you if someone were to shout it out
but um
anyone
have one
ordering food
or yes yes ordering food ordering food
for meetings
putting ordering uh cleaning up after
the meeting scheduling the meeting
putting on a conference like this one
right all those things are really
important to your profession
and to your organization but they don't
help you or they're good for your team
so here's the top 10 lists that we
identified in terms of all the things we
do that are non-promotable
um
so these should look familiar um things
like supporting our co-workers all the
things we do to support one another to
back them up so it might be reviewing
their work covering for them when they
can't attend class
um
helping someone solve a problem so all
those things we do to support co-workers
really important to the organization
and to the university i can talk about
universities with this group
really important to your co-workers but
don't help you advance your own career
all the service work that we do right
serving on oversight committees dee and
i committees logistical planning
committees
all the in academia committee work you
know can be overwhelming
there is the set of things we do to you
know promote group harmony
help other people
resolve conflict or mentor other people
um really important again and then
there's the basic office housework that
we do like taking notes in meetings
ordering the foods cleaning cleaning up
afterward right all of these things need
to get done
they're important to the organization
but unless they're part of your job
they don't advance your career
so that's what we mean by non-promotable
tasks
all right so there may be other things
you do
that are non-promotable and when we step
back and look at all this extra work
that we were doing we kind of
tried to boil them down into their core
components
so what we found that was
similar
across many of these tasks were the
following
um
first
the task we asked whether the task was
instrumental
to improving the organization's bottom
line okay so what does this mean for
academia right so what's the what's the
currency what's the what's important in
org in a university
high quality research and teaching and
service of knowledge creation attracting
students and student success right so
advance
increasing the knowledge base
and teaching
all right so that's so what are the
things that you do that are instrumental
to advancing
that those goals right so we do our
research we conduct research we publish
research we teach our courses
everything else we do
is less instrumental right or maybe
indirectly instrumental to reading those
bottom lines like these committees i was
on a committee to build plan the design
of the business goal
over 30 years i've done it three times
you know organizing social events and so
so far so on
so the next characteristic
is the visibility of the task
so does this track does this task get
tracked
is it monitored
is it visible are your efforts can they
be linked to the output
so if you think about our jobs right
research productivity the answer is yes
that would be promotable teaching
ratings help you you know make your
teaching visible but your service
not really right it's pretty invisible
you know what you're doing but most
other people do not
um the third characteristic
is um does the test require your
specialized skills that which you were
hired to do
or can anyone do this job right so
research research and teaching check
right our specialized skills especially
when we're teaching these advanced
courses that tap into our expertise
um
but the other tasks you know like
ordering food for a meeting that you
brought up doesn't require the skills
you're being trained in and you know as
a theoretician
okay
so when you look at these these are the
three prime character characteristics of
promotable tasks
another question you can ask is is the
task indirectly promotable
so could it help you advance your career
indirectly
right so these are the
tasks that allow you to develop new
skills or meet new people that will give
you connections right
and i put this in parentheses because
it's indirect
it doesn't directly advance your career
it's less promotable in that regard if
you do a little bit of it like the first
time you do it it's great
right but it can be a slippery slope if
you get
if you stay on this committee
for a long period of time you've already
developed those relationships
staying on for much longer you know year
after year doesn't necessarily
serve you well becomes less promotable
over time
okay so that's
the idea of what's promotable so
hopefully that clarified to you
how to think about your work and i'll
talk more about how to use this
information
in um thinking about your own careers
and how you're spending your time
okay so that was the first step the
second step was to say well for us as a
group was is to
ask ourselves is our intuition right
that women are doing more of this work
than men
so
we we looked at it in two ways first of
course we went to the literature to see
what other people have found and here's
an example of one study that's out there
we've and i'll show you these results in
a in a second but there were studies
across industries engineering law
high tech that's the newest one that's
out this report came out in 2022 looking
at uh women in high tech so uh it's by
the same kind of set of authors uh
williams out of the center for work life
law and society worklife law that's um
the central publisher they do the work
but what we see is that across these
different
disciplines and jobs even grocery store
workers and tsa agents and airports
report that the women are doing more
non-promotable work than their male
colleagues in in the context of their
job so here's um results from one study
that was uh based on a survey of
engineers so it was 3 000 engineers
reporting on their access to both
promotable work and non-promotable work
so what you see here is the dark bar on
the far right
that represents the white men
and the bars to the left include women
of various
ethnicities and what you see in terms of
access to promotable work is that the
men report having more
the report being more likely to be
assigned high-profile tasks or work
teams
and um
at the end they say they believe they
have the same access to desirable
colleagues as uh assignments as compared
to their colleagues much more so than do
women and then you know when you look at
different ethnicities there's some
differences as well where for example
the um african-american women felt like
they had less the least access or least
desirable assignments and this has been
repeated in other industries as well
when we look at non-promotable work in
this study they focus specifically on
office housework that i defined earlier
like finding a time when everyone can
meet or taking notes at meetings
planning office parties and so on the
women reported having to do much more of
this than their male colleagues
all right so this is you know
self-report data it's good data but we
wanted to quantify it we were wondering
well how much more time do women spend
at doing this work than their male
colleagues
so to do that we had to get the
cooperation of an organization and we
were able to work in one organization
with a consulting firm
and the great thing about talking to
consulting firms
is that um they keep track of billable
hours like their employees keep track of
how where they're spending their time
both billable and non-billable so they
went back into their data across three
years
and and categorized the work as
promotable and non-promotable and then
compared the total amount of time
that their employees were spending male
and female on this work
so this first graph
uh compares within junior colleagues and
within senior colleagues the total
amount of time women spent in a year
versus men on non-promotable tasks
and what they found
is that regardless of seniority level
the women were spending
200 more hours a year
a non-promotable task as compared to
their male colleagues
like that's a month of extra work
that's that's a lot of time
and these were things like working on
mentoring others doing community service
you know all the things that that they
kept track of
they also collected data on how much
time they were spending on promotable
work
and what they found was that the junior
women right so these were the
non-partners newer in their careers
they were spending 250 fewer hours than
their male colleagues
on their promotable tasks so this was
the billable time this is the stuff that
advances their careers
this is this is a
a trade-off right so maybe they were
doing this to make more room for the
npt's they had to do or maybe they were
given fewer opportunities to do the
promotable work we don't know but again
that's a month less
time spent on career impacting work than
the men spent
right that's that's a problem so think
about this in terms of your own work
spending a month less time in the lab or
in or you know developing theory
whatever you know the primary tasks are
in writing code
than your male colleagues
all right
the senior women was a slightly
different story
uh the median senior woman spent the
same amount of time in their promotable
tasks as a median senior man
she just worked more hours
right so she took this this extra month
of work and put it on top of everything
else
so the inequity of the situation was
very clear
right but the question of course is why
is this happening and what is the impact
on women
i'm going to talk about both all right
so
yeah when we looked at these junior
consultants this is a great example of
what we call work work and balance right
if we talk about work failing family and
imbalance all the time you know we're
spending too much time at work we have
less time for our family well here we're
spending too much time on our
non-promotable tasks that results in
less time available
to work on our promotable tasks the
things that are important to our careers
and of course you can imagine all the
negative impact it can have on your
career right
it's hard to demonstrate and develop
your skills so your career can slow down
the promotions slow down the
raises slow down you might not get um
past your annual review and so on um but
it also has
personal
uh
impact on individuals
we see evidence of a diminished
professional identity right if you
there's this really interesting study of
women in engineering and how
and these were students actually and
they were saddled with all the
administrative tasks in their work teams
the men were getting the exciting
assignments and the women were kind of
backing them up and they really
questioned whether or not
engineering was the right field for them
and some decided to leave
as a result
it's of course emotionally exhausting to
have to
to try to keep up and to try and manage
this balance it can lead to tension with
your male colleagues right when there's
inequities and then of course we see
outcomes in terms of
dissatisfaction with the work
stress
and turnover people leave
there's also of course negative outcomes
when you have work overload you know
this was the story of our senior
consultants who just worked longer hours
you know of course this is going to
spill into your work family balance you
have less time to spend with others
you're when you're working all the time
that can be very isolating right instead
of having time to go out with your
colleagues and socialize you know you're
staying at the office late you're
working in the lab late you're in front
of your computer when other people are
have been able to take a break
um this is you know psychologically
stressful it can lead to burnout it can
be physically stressful it can lead to
hypertension
um
and of course you know when you're
spending all this extra time you know
it's one thing when you have a month of
extra time on work that's advanced in
your career you'll see the payoff
but in this case you're spending a month
of extra time doing work that doesn't
advance your career
and and you don't benefit from it
all right so you know bad all around bad
for women and of course you can imagine
this is bad for organizations as well
because if you want you know if
organizations want
their
employees to succeed holding them back
with non-promotable work is not is going
to hold them back from their advancement
and it's very hard to achieve gender
equity or improvement in the balance
when the women are settled with this
extra work
all right so why does this happen all
right so i'm going to transition a
little bit
so the next question is how does this
happen like is it you know we we thought
maybe we just couldn't say no or is it
because women are getting asked more
well the answer is all of the above
right we found in our research
that women are tend to be asked more to
do non-promotable tasks than their male
colleagues we ran in fact in our
research i'm going to tell you a little
bit about it women were 50 more likely
than men to be asked to do a
non-promotable task
50 more likely to be asked
okay
we also say yes we're more likely to say
yes when we're asked you know asking is
a good strategy because we're more
likely to agree
and i'll show you the data but in our
study 75 of the women said yes when they
were asked when only half the men said
yes
and we volunteer more
women are 50 more likely to volunteer to
do a task that would help the group but
would come at a personal cost themselves
so the question is what's going on like
why is this happening
and what we find in our research this is
the headline it's because we're expected
to
there are these norms and expectations
we expect women to do this work so we
ask them
we have internalized these
expectations
so we say yes
and we volunteer
all right so let me just show you a
little bit about the data for this and
one study that demonstrates kind of
these dynamics
all right
so we ran an experiment
where we brought a bunch of people into
a lab
men and women
and we want to test who volunteers first
to do a task that benefits the group but
comes at a cost to the person doing it
so you know you think about the
situation of um you're all in a meeting
someone has to take notes in the meeting
and and summarize them and distribute
the notes afterwards
everyone benefits from the note taking
and the writing up of the report but
it's time consuming for the person who
does it
so who's going to volunteer to do it
um so in this study there were
mixed sex groups there were men and
women in the room and for each round you
see there's 10 rounds there was a
they were told they were with a random
set and they were with of three people
men and women in the room so they didn't
know the exact gender composition for
each round
and we wanted to see who would volunteer
first
to do the task
and what we found was that across all
the rounds women volunteered first about
a third of the time
okay so that's kind of equitable right
there's groups of three
so you know each one each person should
volunteer about third of the time but
men took a different strategy they
volunteered only 20 of the time
or about twice across the 10 rounds and
these differences were statistically
significant
using whatever test you wanted to use
and men were volunteering less from the
very beginning and this didn't go away
over time so they weren't just waiting
to take their turn
uh this you know happened round after
round after round
so then the next question we had is well
what's driving this is this because
women like are just they're nicer
we're more altruistic
um
and you know if that was the case
if it was a personality thing or
something about our gender then you
would imagine that these would hold
regardless of whatever group we were in
it wouldn't matter
so we ran the same experiment but in
this time this time we did it with
um
same-sex groups so people came in
either all male or all female in terms
of how they self-identified
okay what we found is that the rates of
volunteering change when people knew
they were in groups of all the same sex
we found that the men in the blue lines
here they volunteered more
they increased their rate of
volunteering
where the women decreased their rate of
volunteering they looked around the room
and they said oh it's all women i don't
have to step up first
right
so uh you know the takeaway here is that
people look around the room and they
adjust their behavior based on the
gender of who's in the room
and how they expect them to behave
and of course if these gender
differences in volunteering were just
related to their preferences to
volunteer the behavior shouldn't change
it should stay the same so this was a
really great clue
that this was due to
um
expectations and we ran we measured
individual differences and we controlled
for them statistically and it did the
effect didn't go away
okay
all right
so
the next question we had is well if
these expectations are so
ingrained it should affect who gets
asked to do npts
so we
ran another study where we um
asked
managers to come in
and pick one person to ask to volunteer
okay so like this is a manager who has
to ask someone to take the notes and
send them out
so when you looked at this group
how many people would you could raise
your hand because i can kind of see you
how many people would ask the woman be
more likely to ask the woman than the
man
okay i've just given you so many clues
nobody's moving i see you
nobody would ask the woman first okay
i've also primed you but what would you
naturally do
oh yeah okay all right maybe someone
would what we find
is that when a group contains one woman
one woman and two men the woman is more
likely to get asked
than the man
so about 40 of the time the woman was
asked about 30 the men okay so
maybe that's because well it's just the
only woman in the group so she stood out
more so then the question is well will
this hold if there are two women in the
group
and one man
um
it held
so in this case the women you know just
kind of split the difference and the man
got asked even less only 25 of the time
and what's important to point out
is this was being done by women and men
it's not that women that men i'm sorry
hold this
preference
women and men do
and you know what this preference is
well-founded because as i mentioned
earlier
the women who were asked in the
experiment were 70 75 of them said yes
when the men were asked only half of
them said yes
so it's a good strategy
all right
so hopefully that's convincing that
there's something going on here about
expectations
driving this and then of course the
question is why do we expect why do we
expect to do women more than this
and there's a lot of reasons and i'll
summarize these quickly because i do
want to
talk about what we can do to manage
ourselves in the situations right but we
have to understand the reasons why so we
have the best strategies
so one is um we ask people who we know
will say yes i've just given you
evidence of that
there's a lot of
evident research that shows that
uh we think we um
pull up in our on our minds um a
prototype or a stereotype of who is the
right person to do the work or a good
fit and women are more likely to come to
mind than men because you know
in society women tend to be in this role
of the helper we do this more at home
maybe those norms transfer to the
workplace and so we just think of women
more easily
also you know practice makes perfect and
if women have historically done this
work we get good at it
and so you know we're like the kind of
victims of our own success
um of course men could easily do the
work and become just as good at it
because it doesn't require this any
specialized skills that we bring to
ourselves bring with ourselves to the
table
another reason women get asked to do
these non-promotable tasks more is what
people talk uh call cultural taxation
so i'm sure this is something that you
will experience if you haven't being in
a field where women are underrepresented
right so there's fewer women than men
let's say there's 20 percent of the
women on the faculty are women but
oftentimes we say well we want 50
representation on our committees of
women
so the women get over sampled right
you're going to go to women more and
more often to make sure we have women on
every committee of course the problem is
there aren't enough women to go around
and so we get taxed as a result of the
cultural group that we belong to
and as you can imagine this is
an even bigger problem
for women in underrepresented groups
so women of color
face this both in terms of their race as
as well in terms of their gender
and they really
get
tapped into and over taxed
as a result
and then finally the last
category is what we talk about is
benevolent sexism right these are people
who are really well intentioned they
want to help us
but what so they give us opportunities
to network and to do special leadership
sessions and so on but it pulls us away
from the time we have to do our
research and it inadvertently does more
harm than good
okay so these are
many reasons why this happens
all right so
what's notable about this again is it's
not because we don't know how to say no
it's because we're
being asked
to say yes
that's coupled with the fact that we're
expected to say yes so we can't just say
no
because it could backfire right
and this is the you know the question we
get all the time are what are some
strategies we can use
to fix the problem for ourselves
so that we're we're still um viewed
positively in the organization and we
can free up our time to balance out our
workload
so i'm going to talk about three sets of
strategies the first set is all the
things you do to
you know we want to we need to resist
the urge to volunteer
you know and oftentimes you look around
the room and say oh i'm just going to do
it it'll be easier for me to do it than
someone else
because i've done it before but we want
to resist that urge so i'm going to talk
something about some things you can do
to help yourself in that regard want to
learn how to say no and avoid negative
repercussions
and then also think about what npt's you
want to say yes to that actually help
you feel good for you and good for your
career
so i'll start with the first
how to you what do you do before saying
yes
okay
so um
the first step is to slow the process
down
so instead of that immediate response of
happy to brenda in in her club she
always whenever anyone asked her to do a
non-promotable task her gut response was
to say happy to you know i'm the team
player i can help and it kind of made
her feel good
but um so the first thing was to break
that habit that she actually wasn't
happy to do all this stuff
and she needed to have some time to
decide
uh
linda put in this thing called she
called it the 24 hour rule that she
would never she would she would say yes
sorry she'd say no right away but she
wouldn't she'd wait 24 hours before
she'd say no
see let me get back to you whether it
was an email or a phone call or even a a
request that was made in the hallway if
this request was going to take time
she would take the time to decide and in
that time
you need to take the to collect
information right get the information
you need to understand the task and
think about who's offer who's asking you
is this someone you can say no to
is this someone who has you know
authority over you and and how do you
want to approach them
uh given the situation
the next step
you know after you assess the the ask
itself is look at your own time
and make a good assessment about what
the cost to you will be of saying yes
and not to underestimate it because
there are
there's research saying we tend to
underestimate the cost of saying yes
um often because we don't consider what
we're giving up when we say yes so
what's your implicit no
so for lisa this uh it was her family
because she was in work overload so she
actually put a post-it
on her computer that reminded her to
think of her kids
every time she was asked to review
another paper or help another colleague
or serve on another committee
that was her implicit no she'd be saying
no to them if she was saying yes to this
also think about yourself in the future
you know if you're asked to do something
a month from now your calendar looks
pretty open
but your calendar is going to be just as
full then as it is going to be next week
so
remember the future you is going to look
a lot like the present you
and do you have time for to to fit this
in
uh finally beware of that your triggers
like for me my trigger was
um
i
i
felt good about being asked i felt
empowered like oh aren't you know i have
something and someone needs some help
and i can help them and um
i had to kind of put that in check a
little bit is it and this was kind of my
diva moment i could feel good about
being asked but i didn't have to
actually do the work
to feel good
um
for me another trigger was i felt guilty
about saying no because i wanted to be
this team player i wanted to be the
helper
and i had to realize that i was still a
team player even though i couldn't
help this other person out
so all these things
come into play well to help you avoid
getting cornered into saying yes
the second set of and so in the book you
know which i do hope you're you'll pick
up and grab a copy um
we get a lot of practical suggestions
about how to do that the second is how
do you say no while avoiding negative
repercussions and this comes
the basic set of
suggestions here
involve putting limits
on what you can do
and what you will agree to
and negoti negotiating so the first
thing is if you can find an alternative
that solves their problem that doesn't
involve you taking on the task
that's great as long as you're not
pushing it on to another woman who's
just as busy right so trying to find a
male colleague who's never done it
before or someone who might benefit from
doing the task this time because you've
already done it five times or maybe even
suggesting someone in another role who
might be more appropriate to do this
task you know
as a faculty member
i've organized you know helped to do
logistics on conferences for the
university you know for my field but
finding an administrative assistant who
could actually learn the task and make
it part of their job
was good for them and good for me
so putting some conditions on your yes
is another you know i can do it now this
time but you know why doesn't joe shadow
me this time and he can pick it up next
time or ask for additional resources and
support
set time limits you know i can do this
for the next week but not forever i can
do it this time but not next time it
doesn't the work you do doesn't have to
be perfect that's you know puts limit on
it as well
but you know turning this into a
negotiation saying
look you uh you need help
i need
to protect my time you know i'm busy
here's the things i have going on right
now let's try to find a way to help let
me help you figure a way to solve your
problem again without me taking it on
and we have lots of solutions that you
can consider
also forming a no club and brainstorming
solutions that work within your context
is a great thing to do all right so this
is about saying no responding to
requests
and getting that was the first thing we
needed to do we had to just
be able to deal with the barrage of
requests we were getting
then we learned to take a step back
and look at our whole portfolio of
non-promotable tasks to figure out how
we can bring it into line with what our
male colleagues were doing
um
through a process of assessment and
adjustment
so first you know there's a series of
questions you can ask yourself in
assessing your workload
how do you how do you spend your time on
promotable and non-promotable tasks how
do others spend their time especially
your male colleagues
what are the expectations of the
organization you know the university of
your department
and once you have that a good sense of
those factors then you can start
thinking well how do you want to spend
your time
and which npts are right for you
all right i'm going to get to that in a
second once you've done this assessment
hopefully with input from more senior
colleagues who have a sense of what you
should be doing and what's promotable
and not promotable
then you can start figuring out
what adjustments you can make what can
you let go of what
who can take it on if you know
to balance out the load
and who's going to help you make the
change
all right so this is these are these can
be done in conversations again with
mentors
with your no club
with your
department chair
with senior colleagues at this
conference these are good conversations
to have in your network
to figure out the answers to these
questions
[Music]
so once you figure out what the right
load is and what you want to get rid of
and hopefully find some ways to start
distributing that more equitably
and i'm going to talk a little bit more
about that
you can
look at your amputees that are left to
decide which you want to keep because of
course everybody needs to do some so
let's find the ones that are best for us
and this was my strategy right
i really focused on non-promotable tasks
that i wanted to do and that leveraged
my expertise so if i was going to be on
a university committee it will be one
that leveraged my expertise in
collaboration and teamwork
and on organizational behavior right so
and the things that i cared about so i
really use those as filters about you
know what to sign on to
um these were you know i tried to choose
ones that were good returns on my time
although i personally i wasn't so good
at that but my colleagues were better at
it um things that kind of gave me gave
me a mental break you know from my like
you just for me you know when i was
working on my research you know very
labor intensive but the payoff
is so takes so long to get a paper
published especially in my field
some of the administrative work i did in
the non-promotable tasks were enjoyable
to me because it kind of fit in with my
current workload i was able to do some
things that gave me immediate feedback
and i knew was having an impact
even like mentoring junior faculty or
or putting on a conference or
whatever it was um organizing something
some of that was kind of fun because i
felt like i was having an immediate
impact
all right so
these are things you can do individually
to manage your own npt load
and i really believe that you know
that's a first step in getting a sense
of your own work life
and that's what we did in the club but
after that you know we realize and
you'll realize that the requests keep
coming in
and you look at your female colleagues
and they'll be in in the same situation
so
the next question is well what can we do
and what can organizations do what can
universities do and departments do to
fix the problem so that we stop
receiving these additional requests
and and feel this pressure to say yes
all right so as individuals we can see
change you know think about bottom-up
change efforts we have some agency
and you know there's two steps one is
creating awareness
getting people to use the term
non-promotable tasks to think about
their work in terms of how they should
be spending their time and you know
recognizing the fact that these
that um
everybody needs to contribute to
beyond their career enhancing work but
the women
shouldn't be doing more of it than the
men
so you know you can talk about the issue
in relatable terms
you know recognize the fact that look if
the university department is trying to
improve gender equity
this is an important thing to look at so
you're tying it to the important goals
of the department
persistence is key bringing it up
whenever the opportunity arises and
enlisting allies
you know your male colleagues who care
about this your department heads in lab
um you know your faculty who care about
this um
the administration and so on so
and also members of other affinity
groups that are you know have
are facing a similar burden so there's
creating awareness
and we find that once people start
talking about it once you start seeing
it it's hard to unsee
and then the second step is you know
with that information and that knowledge
what can you do
you know interrupt the status quo so if
you're in a meeting and you see that one
of your female colleagues is being
voluntold to take on a non-promotable
task you can interrupt it by saying hey
wait you know jennifer did it last time
um
maybe you know kevin can take it on this
time
uh so you know speaking up and
advocating
um suggesting different ways to hand out
the task instead of
you know
when someone says is there a volunteer
before anyone can volunteer speak up and
say you know we know that volunteers
tend to be women why don't we just take
turns
you know or if someone volunteers and
they did it last time say you know what
you did it last time maybe someone else
can pick it up this time
so you we're basically um
engaging in whatever power we have to
get people to start changing their
habits of how this work is taken on
those of you who are a little bit more
senior start mentoring early career
colleagues so that they know which you
know which is what's promotable and
what's not uh sometimes junior
colleagues feel that if they're asked to
do something it must be important
but if you were not effectively mentored
you may not realize that the task is
actually non-promotable
so a
bunch of ideas we
suggest
okay well the goal here right is uh once
we've started seeding the change is to
get our managers our
senior faculty our department heads to
start thinking about their work units
you know their labs their
um
departments
to both change how work is distributed
educating the employees about what's
promotable and not and redesigning and
redistributed redistributing current
so doing the things that make sure we
have everybody stepping up to the plate
to do these tasks not saying that
everybody has to do everything
right like i can
i um
i don't know you know like if it's
bringing in food for the
department meeting like i don't cook so
it's not gonna be me but so maybe
someone else does like i don't have to
do every non-promotable task but if
everyone's sharing an equal load
we'll all be in a better place
and then of course we can think about
how organizations can fix a problem in
terms of more and this is thinking about
our rpt uh reappointment and promotion
and tenure processes you know what are
the expectations
for doing non-promotable tests or
service work
and then enforcing standards so there's
a great um you know anecdote out of um
the harvard kennedy school that's their
school of public policy so when our work
first came out a few years ago
they took a look at their requirements
for
service
and actually set a floor in terms of a
minimum and they set up a point system
so that
if you weren't doing enough service you
actually had to pick up extra work in
other domains or
you know and balance things out so there
was some accountability
and then what we suggest is put a cap on
it as well so people aren't doing too
much of this work
um
providing incentives to do the work
so if someone's doing a lot of service
you know maybe we give them a
reduction in their teaching load
um
if they're in a research oriented
position or if they're a teaching
faculty
maybe you know maybe there's some other
incentive we can give them
so we're thinking about redesigning jobs
making sure the right tasks are in the
right places um providing feedback and
tracking how much service people are
doing and so on so all these things are
the types of solutions that will fix the
problem in the long term
so i like talking to groups you know
organizational leaders as well
to give them the tools to fix the
problem and so as you all go back to
your institutions
talk to your department heads talk to
your you know whoever you have access to
to start getting them thinking about
this and what they can do to fix the
problem when you're done with the book
pass it on to someone else to read
um and because in the end you know
organizations that fix the problem will
improve gender equity they'll have a
better strike
more supportive culture
they use their workforce more
efficiently
people will be more satisfied and
engaged um and they'll be a better place
to work they'll be more likely to be
able to attract women and retain women
and isn't that what you know we're all
trying to do
um at this point in time
so with that um i'm going to stop my
comments i think we still have a good
amount of time for q a
the um the book you know
is available it you know it's been paid
for
by the conference so it's free to you
i believe that's the case
correct me if i'm wrong but um i think
that's what we talked about and so what
you'll be able to do is is take this
with you and what you're going to see in
the book
it's very practical it's written for you
it's got exercises and you know little
um
questions you can answer to help you do
your assessment of your work um
and
and balance out the load so i really
hope that you know you find this to be
really useful for you and your careers
and the careers
of your colleagues as well so with that
i'll stop talking and turn it over to
back to you
and i don't hear anything coming out of
the room right now so i don't know if
it's muted but
um if you want to pass around a
microphone or but i'm sure you have lots
of questions
thank you
um so i was wondering you mentioned that
you did some experiments where you ask
groups of only men to volunteer
um
in those experiments
do men tend to volunteer very equally or
were there characteristics that made it
like more or less likely like when
there's no women in the room what
uh what factors tend to emerge
yeah so in this study because it was an
experimental setting and they didn't
know
characteristics of the others some of
that was random assignment and washed
out
um in general though we see
um that people who have a more
cooperative tendencies you know
personality wise
tend to volunteer more so if there's
some individual differences that will
probably come that will come into play
with the men just like it will with the
women once you pull gender out of the
equation
there are some personality factors in
this situation there were no status
differences among the men
so but you could imagine in the
workplace you might see people in lower
status positions or lower levels of
seniority
being the ones to do this
more so than than higher status so you
can imagine those those things will come
into play
oh hi thank you for the talk i mean uh
this is very close to what i'm currently
like working on like trying to say no to
things and i'm definitely going to like
use some of the things that you have
said so one thing that i was wondering
that if um so the example that you give
that um sometimes like maybe your girl
is asked to a woman is asked to do
something but somebody can um
say that okay give this to kevin uh the
problem is what if kevin doesn't do it
from all his heart and then
you end up like the task giver had to
like take the burden off okay this is
not done now i have to do so how do you
how do you deal with this decision
asking from the end that sometimes i
also when i work with phd students i i
guess if if there are things that
requires more like creative things
somehow i tend to pick like
women and i feel like they'll do it with
all their heart but maybe that's wrong
and i'm just deciding like
yeah so you're in a perfect position
to change the norms
right so the the um
we have to hold men accountable to do
this work
like that's the bottom line you know
there's this there's research on feign
incompetence you know where and where
men are more likely to feign
incompetence than our women to get out
of doing this work uh or any type of you
know low status work
the um
having an explicit conversation about it
outside of the task allocation is a
great tool
because you can have a you know
conversation with your group that says
with all your graduate students that say
you know i've read this book i've come
you know i'm starting to think more
about who's doing what in the in in the
group and i'm realizing that you know
um or you just you don't even talk about
the past just the current i want to make
sure that everybody is
doing their fair share
so i'm going to start
being more intentional about who i asked
to do these things and i want to be
clear that you know everybody is being
held to the same level of expectations
to carry the work out
and in your position of authority
by saying that and then of course
walking the talk and holding the male
students accountable
and once they realize they're being held
accountable you'll be in a better place
now if let's say though this is the
first time your male student has ever
done this task before you can give them
some support and say okay you know
whatever woman has done in the past will
work with you what is available to you
to give you tips and pointers or maybe
she'll do you two will do it together
this time and next time it'll be your
responsibility
does that help yeah definitely thank you
so much great
if do you want me to stop sharing my
slides without help
will you see me bigger that way if i
stop doing that
yes yeah let me do that i know my
all right good you see me better now
all right great go ahead i love you i
don't know if i'm a big head on the
screen now or what but
i'll try to thank you so much for your
talk um so one of the suggestions you
suggested was like uh have like a
minimum service requirement for
everybody so this is actually something
we tried to make happen in our
department
and so a few women who realized that all
of the service work just fell on women
telling people of color said what if we
had a mandatory service requirement
and so
what happened
[Laughter]
very very strong pushback from very
vocal male students a few
like at one point like someone replied
being like i don't i don't think serving
the community or even improving the
world is a necessary part of the of
getting a phd
um so my question is the wrong culture
and like
i i it just feels like there's
like if if if for the men who are not
saying yes have feel this culture of
like oh i don't need to do it because
these women will do it and like i don't
know how to shift the culture as women
other than like
it it's like means that it seems like a
race to the bottom because if no one
does things they'll just like get worse
and worse and like there's such like
resistance i mean to be fair
this is a vocal minority of many scenes
in the department yes absolutely they
are sure
very vocal
they are very vocal and i see this since
our book came out by the way when if you
read some of the comment boards you see
this vocal minority of men
and up in arms that we could even
suggest this that men would ever do this
work
but
that aside um
so
couple things so one is um
it is a race to the bottom and
you know i and setting expectations and
norms and basically saying
there's a whole range of non-promotable
tasks
and
not everyone is going to be doing
everything and so you know
you can choose amongst them something
that you find to be most appealing
but
this is the foundation of what
you know helps the department run and
everybody has a responsibility and of
course it has to come from someone in a
position of authority and and you have
to carry through
um
so you know it ends up walking the talk
um the
in getting you know this coming from the
men as not just the women right if um in
terms of the male
who are not pushing back on this and
understand you know they have a role to
play there are some men that you're
never going to win over and if you spend
all your time dealing with them nothing
will ever happen so you want to so you
know it's a little bit about not giving
them the oxygen and focusing on
the 80 of people who are going to be
behind you and making it happen and then
the 20
will come along or they won't and if
they continue to free ride
then you know the leadership has to
decide
what how much they're going to tolerate
that
right and so that that's a that's a
decision to be made
so it is you know culture change has to
come from the top
and if the if the if there's leadership
that allow people to say not my
problem
then it will continue to not be their
problem
so um yeah so i think that's that's an
issue
to be dealt with
it's tough the culture change is the
hardest behavioral change is easier so i
always say start with the behavioral
change
and hopefully the you know the hearts
will follow
i mean of course the other thing you
know suggestion which is the radical one
is just that the women go on strike
like if we stop doing it then they'll
see hey guess what
this stuff does matter
and i wouldn't hold that out
off you know completely off the table
if you want to get a point across
uh yeah so i actually have
the two questions
uh my first one is
a related
to this ideas basically
as you're mentioning that
culture change um
has
to come from the top but i often find
that as i'm sure
everyone here knows that men often
occupy those
already existing
positions of authority and
i guess my question is
where do you imagine we find the
leverage necessary
in order to actually hold
let's say you have a conversation with
your
department chair and in the meeting they
go oh you know that's a good idea i'll
think about it i'll go over it
and then nothing happens right like so
where where does the leverage come from
right so um
this is why the seating change
strategies are so important if you can't
engage your
department chair
um
then you know there's things you can do
and more stealth moves to kind of
introduce more equitable distribution
you know i gave you some examples but
you know you do it at the moment
you know and you start saying no a
little bit more and then explain why
right so there's
there and you give tools you know you
problem solve with them in terms of how
to how to make sure this is equitably
distributed
um
[Music]
another thing i'll say is just because
there's a man in a leadership position
doesn't mean he doesn't understand this
problem and doesn't want to fix the
problem because i have
met more male leaders
who
this opens their eyes and they really
want to fix it and and they try to find
ways in their organizational context in
their department
to make sure that they're not
contributing to the problem minimally so
look for those people
and
there is evidence that
you know of course there are people who
just care about gender equity we also
find that men who have daughters
and wives
and
partners who are female
and um
[Music]
uh also men of color who have
experienced this themselves
um
[Music]
they are more likely to be open to
gender equity and racial equity types of
issues and are potentially a more
natural ally
i mean i actually also had one more
question
on the issue of intersectionality i know
you mentioned earlier some interests
also intersectionality with race um and
ethnicity
and
one of the things on my mind is um
is if there's any research
where you've seen anything about um
intersectionality
and these sorts of npts with um
and i uh with both
queer people
um
either the gender identity or yes
the sexuality and also um
a disability
really great question the research isn't
there like i just don't know in terms of
the data
um
i can speculate
right and i can speculate that
gay men
who present themselves potentially as
more effeminate may
may be pigeon like stereotyped
with more female attributes and
therefore expected to do more
non-promotable tasks but that is pure
speculation i have no idea um
and i would love for people to study
that what we're really hoping is that
this book and our research spurs more
research
on the drivers of this the impact it has
on organizations and what we can do to
fix it more broadly speaking
yeah so i i just i haven't we haven't
found the research it i don't think it's
been done
thank you thanks for that question
thank you for your talk um i had a
question about how
um how you might recommend navigating
um
what appears to me like the the
differential
um way in which like men and women
are penalized
for for incompetence either found or for
otherwise with non-promotable tasks
where i feel like
you know especially in theory or like
stem fields um sometimes incompetence
with these tests is one was taken if
you're a man as proof of confidence in
promotable tests right where it's like
oh we would never expect this person to
you know be capable of organizing an
event um they're just like one of those
brilliant you know like geniuses their
heads always in the clouds etc etc
whereas i feel like
when a woman demonstrates the same sort
of maybe lack of organizational skills
that she's like a you know flighty or
ditzy um and i feel like there's like
it's it's like a penalty rather than
yeah um like like proof of some sort and
if you have any suggestions for how to i
don't know combat this or navigate it if
not about it yeah the
best thing to do
is name the problem so you call it out
not necessarily in the moment because
you don't want to make an enemy but um
recognizing that this happens right and
so if we and in reminding someone when
they say oh you know
seth can't do this or
raj can't do this because you know he's
too he's you know the genius scientist
um
you know the question is why not now now
on that one hand if he really is
the
the best way he can spend his time is in
his doing his research
then we want to find ways he can
contribute that don't interfere with
that like yeah we want to take research
productivity into account we need to do
the same thing for the women like we
have genius women we don't want to be
saddling them so let's treat
all the people in these different strata
similarly
right so that and having that
conversation so if you're just as you
know
success you know just as smart there's
no reason why and successful there's no
reason why you should be doing more of
this than your male colleagues
so maybe both of you should be doing
less it's not that he should do more
maybe like we're gonna pay attention to
that so again taking this into account
that's one thing
um and
yeah i i
i mean it's really hard to change that
when
um but we do you know i said i saw a
little thing on the side that said do a
b plus rather than an a-plus job
a non-promotable test
like we need to stop killing ourselves
to to be perfect
in everything we do
and if there's one area where we can
lower our standards
it's a non-promotable work
we want to be the best
in our in our research
you know
and our
whatever our teaching we want to excel
but when it comes to
um the non-promotable work
you don't have to do it perfectly and
and i think sometimes as women
we have you know we're so used to having
to be the best at anything to be
recognized because especially when
you're in a male dominated field
that we carry that over into everything
we do
and
you know you just don't have to do that
and that was a lesson i had to learn by
the way
that was a personal
lesson but um it really it's true
thank you
yeah i had a question about um cultural
taxation um i guess just like in terms
of like short-term solutions it seems to
me like to be one of the hardest things
to like i mean just like the presence of
a woman on a committee is like not
something that you can like you know i
guess like i so this is like a question
of like training people to like be able
to you know like represent more diverse
viewpoints when they're sitting on
committees even if they don't hold those
identities or like i guess what like i
was curious about like your short-term
solutions for those i mean before you
know like we just get more women in the
department or whatever
yeah the best way to solve this problem
is the leadership approach and and to
look at
um the reason
each committee that you're composing
each of us that you're making and and if
you do need diversity of experience and
diversity of background then um to make
sure that you're
unloading those people with other work
but for individuals what i always say is
um when i'm asked
yeah
i'm being recorded so i have to be
careful of what i say but
i think i always used to joke
that if the only reason i'm being asked
to be on a committee is because i have a
certain set of physical characteristics
i'll just let you fill in the blanks
um
and that's it then the answer is no
right but if it's something about my
expertise
my perspective what i bring to the table
then i'll consider it right but if it's
just you know like i've served on
more initiatives over the 30 years 35
years of my career
for diversity equity and inclusion and
increasing the representation of women
in the academy
um
that was important to me because
it's one of my it me it's
a concern that i have i want you know
it's something i care about i will say
yes that i'm not being asked to do just
because i'm a woman
but i'm sure that's part of it but it's
also because i have expertise
in organizational behavior and thinking
about gender equity and so on so that's
something but if you're going to ask me
to serve on a committee
to um
you know
oh
for a curriculum review
because you want more you want equal
representation of men and women i'm like
thanks but no thanks you know not gonna
happen
does that help
yeah definitely yeah great
and i know i only have a couple more
minutes i believe i think we started a
little late
okay uh thank you for your talk
uh often when i have these
i don't know social organizing social
events i feel like when i don't do them
they don't happen that
some
people like they just don't initiate
them but they benefit from them they
enjoy them and i benefit them from them
and i enjoy them but
i find it hard to
get this to happen without me being
directly involved
[Music]
so do you have any tips or
um
so i think that the first question is
well have you had a explicit
conversation about this
no
that's the first step just say hey i
know everybody's really enjoying these
gatherings i love them too it takes me a
lot of time would someone be willing to
do it next time just ask
and you'll be surprised someone will
step up and if they say well i would
love to but i don't really know say well
let's do it together this time and then
you can organize the next one just i
find also that asking and saying hey
look
can we just take turns on this
um you know as can someone else host
next time
i'm guessing you'll get someone to step
up now maybe another woman
so
you could be even more explicit and say
can we take turns and everybody take a
turn
so you know maybe a woman will pick it
up next time but one of the guys will do
at the time after that and keep track
thank you
[Music]
um yeah
hi um uh it's actually kind of more of a
quick comment based on the question
before last um
i heard that at uh at columbia like one
thing that they do for
their dei stuff is that they have like
one kind of
committee that's like kind of here's the
big overarching like direction we want
to go in and then another committee for
like implementing
and so um the implementation committee
maybe has a bunch of you know like white
men on it who you know aren't doing
enough of this work versus um
the people who are kind of setting the
agenda um
bring those um more diverse perspectives
of what needs to get done no interesting
don't do all the work of temple engine
yeah that's really interesting i'd be
really interested to see how
if the implementation that they
put forth matches the vision
of the you know that's that higher level
thinking committee i think that's great
i mean the idea again is you know think
about how the work is distributed and
get the right people on the right doing
the right activities so that's really
interesting thank you for sharing that
so i think we are out of time
yeah thank you
my pleasure my pleasure so glad to be
able to uh
join you sorry i couldn't be there in
person
i think they muted at the other end it
just i just stopped hearing anything
thanks very much thank you so much for
doing this
i think we all learned a lot and this is
a really valuable lesson
bye-bye thanks so so much enjoy the rest
of your conference bye-bye